ce que l'émir poutine qu'ils jugent donc
à vous l'avez dit malgré tout
constructif son échange avec joe biden
même son de cloche du côté du président
ukrainien qui salue des discussions
positives alors va-t-on vers une
désescalade sur ce dossier ukrainien
derrière les mots quelles intentions
réelles
l'extension de l'otan vers l'est est
elle une menace réelle on décrypte la
situation avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct alexandre del valle
géopolitologue docteur en histoire
contemporaine je rappelle que vous êtes
aussi co auteur du livre la
mondialisation dangereuse vers le
déclassement de l'occident aux éditions
l'artilleur bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés toujours en direct jean
de gliniasty directeur adjoint de l'iris
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
bonsoir jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous et sur ce plateau max erwan
gastineau politologue spécialiste de
l'europe centrale bonsoir à vous alors
on vient de l'entente d'un joe biden qui
qui persiste et signe un il manque les
muscles au lendemain de cet entretien il
menace une nouvelle fois venir poutine
de sanctions en cas d'attaqué 1 comme il
n'en avait jamais vu comment alexandre
del valle interpréter ces mots assez
durs que beaucoup d'observateurs alors
que beaucoup d'observateurs parlé ce
matin de de désescalade
en fait non il ya une grande constance
vous savez depuis les années 90 c'est le
problème qui dure depuis très longtemps
qui n'a jamais été réglé parce que
l'europe est un espace atlantiste et les
états unis n'ont jamais renoncé surtout
depuis 2003 2004 2005 à à recréer une
forme de niro comme times d'avoir de
lourdes bac les stratégies les plus
dures sous la guerre froide et l'accord
tacite qui avaient été trouvées au
sortir de l'union soviétique en union
soviétique c'était s'est collé sa vie y
avait un accord tacite de non-agression
et l'occident en échange du fait que la
russie avait aboli le pacte de varsovie
l'occident n'allait pas dans les lignes
rouges et mettant des pinsons espace
atlantiste parce que c'est simple m trop
vers l'est les pays baltes ça a été la
limite acceptable et la russie pardon
l'ukraine c'est la ligne rouge comme
comme comme la géorgie et
malheureusement les américains n'ont pas
donné de signes certes très positif
officielle pour que la l'ukraine rentrer
de longtemps un jour mais il ya une
forte demande en ce sens en ukraine et
les russes ont l'impression que même si
ce n'est pas officiel que les etats-unis
encouragent en sous-main cette atlantide
à sion progressive à venir de ce pays
qui serait vraiment dramatique pour les
relations volcy occident et ce problème
dure depuis 30 ans et malheureusement
l'occident l'occident n'a pas compris
que ce serait intelligent de trouver un
modus vivendi à un accord me voir même
un statu quo ce n'est pas forcément un
accord extraordinaire mais on dirait que
l'occident est très sûr de lui-même et
méprise cet espace post soviétique
qui ne méritent même pas le respect d'un
accord certes officieux des années 90
parce que vous savez pour les etats-unis
la russie c'est un pays je m'excuse et
roger guerre mais c'est ce que disent
les américains en voie de
clochardisation les américains ne
respecte que l'argent est pour une
puissance qui a le budget de la à peine
de l'italie - que la france ne mérite
pas d'être à parité et bien sûr la
russie cherche à paraître à parité il ya
ce mépris fondamental de ce qu'est la
russie et je pense que malheureusement
la tension n'est pas à la fin ça ne peut
que continuer jean de gliniasty c'est
vrai que souvent les rues sander on l'a
vu avec toutes les réactions
occidentales aujourd'hui des pays
d'europe qui louait la souveraineté de
l'ukraine les russes qui n'ont pas le
beau rôle dans cette affaire pour les
occidentaux alexandre del valle halal a
rappelé l'otan a été créée on s'en
souvient qui entier rappel historique
justement au lendemain de la au début de
la guerre froide comme instrument
politique et militaire pour empêcher
l'invasion des pays d'europe parole rsa
c'est ce qu'on assiste pas quand même
depuis plusieurs années à une forme de
retour aux sources et on comprend
peut-être aussi l'agacement des des
russes
oui alors
la question c'est sûr que nous sommes
dans une nouveau type de guerre froide
et que les russes ont mis très
clairement une ligne rouge qui est pas
de pas de temps en ukraine jeudi pas de
temps 9ème parce que en fait les russes
se sont rendus compte que c'est pas
seulement une question d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan et que le temps à de
multiples moyens de coopérer avec lui
prennent sans une adhésion formelle
donc par exemple qu'un programme
s'appelle rennsport notice qui permet de
coopérer ce plan militaire de façon très
intense de former des officiers
d'envoyer du matériel
donc on peut peut-être expliquer le
les concentrations de troupes récente
par la volonté russe de faire monter les
enchères et de d'inclure dans la
corbeille qui a été négocié l'on ne sait
pas exactement ce qui s'est dit à genève
20 ans et une visioconférence pardon
donc d'inclure cet aspect là sur le fond
tout le monde est content et très
probablement on va arriver vers une
désescalade les le poutine a dit qu'il
était content
zelensky a dit qu'il était content et
alors que en fait pour lui c'est plutôt
un recul dans la mesure où le les
américains ont dit qu'il n'enverrait pas
de troupes en fait et donc les
américains
font des moulinets si je puis dire en
disant il peut y avoir des sanctions
très grave mais alors même qu'ils ont
dit qu'il n'interviendrait pas
militairement
directement donc en fait je pense qu'on
va faire après toute cette gesticulation
part et d'autre on va vers une
désescalade un autre élément que je
voudrais souligner c'est que
pendant très longtemps les américains
ont laissé en fait aux européens le soin
de s'occuper de l'ukraine en première
ligne et là le blocage persistant des
accords de mines ce que fait que les
américains ont repris les affaires en
mains si je puis dire et ils ont repris
les affaires en main avec une idée très
claire c'est que leur priorité c'est la
rivalité avec la chine et que ils n'ont
pas besoin en fait une conflagration
d'une déflagration en outre elle est
donc c'est un élément supplémentaire qui
me fait penser à une désescalade max et
roanne à gatineau justement vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'europe centrale
l'europe à jean de gliniasty viens d'en
parler c'est vrai qu'elle a été un petit
peu mise à l'écart dans ce dossier
veilleux potiner joe biden ont parlé
égal à égal c'est d'ailleurs une forme
de victoire certainement pour la russie
avec une europe qui est arrivé un petit
peu en ce bon plan oui quand on quand on
parle de la crise ukrainienne on entend
parler de deux acteurs la russie et les
occidentaux je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire les occidentaux en fait ce sont les
américains mais quelle est la position
de l'union européenne dans ce conflit
qu'elle est plus globalement la
politique orientale de l'union
européenne au début du mandat de
l'ursuya van der leyen président de la
commission européenne il était question
d'instituer une commission géopolitique
on en voit toujours pas si vous voulez
la couleur on peut d'ailleurs faire un
parallèle avec le conflit qui a lieu
actuellement entre
la pologne et la biélorussie avec un
certain nombre de migrants qui ont été
donc massés à la frontière polonaise
lorsqu'on regarde les réactions et
la manière dont l'union européenne se
saisit de ces sujets on voit une
commission je dirais plus - européenne
connus viennent on va de sanctions en
grand discours sur les valeurs en grands
discours moreau mais on ne voit pas
vraiment de vision stratégique de vision
politique qui permettrait enfin à
l'union européenne
de créer un nouvel espace de discussion
plus apaisée avec la russie puisque en
effet contrairement aux américains ça
n'aura échappé à personne l'europe est
une faune a une frontière commune avec
des états proches de la russie je crois
que nous avons intérêt en effet à
peut-être refonder d'une nouvelle
relation c'était d'ailleurs le sens de
ce que emmanuel macron avait déclaré
dans un grand discours aux ambassadeurs
l'ennemi n'est pas alès l'ennemi est
ailleurs les miettes au sud il
a réitéré cette volonté d'apaisement
mais on ne voit pas concrètement encore
aujourd'hui les fruits de cette volonté
de réorienter l'union européenne de
telle sorte qu'elle s'émancipe d'un
giron américain qui en effet
participe de cette atmosphère de
tensions avec la russie qui se traduit
aujourd'hui concrètement à la frontière
russo ukrainienne elle est sans del
valle emmanuel macron qu'il va prendre
la tête de la présidente présidence
tournante de l'europe à ce que les
choses peuvent changer c'est vrai que il
a exprimé hier et virilité d'apaisement
avec vladimir poutine mais c'est vrai
que c'est un peu toujours le un show et
froid
oui c'est un peu chaud mais il est
certain que les pays ont quand même des
traditions nationales
indépendamment des majorités et la
france est quand même avec deux ou trois
autres pays de l'union européenne des
moins favorable à une tension et poutine
a dit quelque chose qui n'est pas tout à
fait faux même si ces pro domo quand il
a souligné que ce sont des pays de la
nouvelle europe sous-entendu les
derniers arrivés qui sont des pays de
l'est assez russophobe ou en tout cas
très méfiant vis-à-vis de la russie qui
souvent ne pousse les les milieux de la
lancia de l'alliance atlantique et les
pays de l'union européenne à ne pas
améliorer les relations en tout cas la
france quand même le pays qui prône le
priche en faveur de cette de ce dialogue
parce que chaque pays a des intérêts et
il est vrai que d'un point de vue
polonais même relativement objectivement
sans être anti russe la russie peut être
vu comme une menace n'est pas du tout
deux points de vue français ou même
italien est donc cette extrême division
des pays européens rang eu une position
commune assez difficile mais il ya aussi
la guerre du gaz qui ne faut pas oublier
aujourd'hui et la rivalité entre le pays
qui voudraient exporter des gaz de
schiste et son rival économique la
russie qui qui avec notamment la
question de nord stream 2 qui
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez est
bloquée pas uniquement par la volonté
américaine mais aussi par les mesures
anti monopole européenne qui empêche le
une grande entreprise comme gastronomes
des gazprom des peut-être également
propriétaire des infrastructures et des
pipelines et donc il ya aussi cette
dimension qui est extrêmement importante
et il y a aussi le double jeu de la
turquie qui tantôt se rapproche de l'os
et s est tantôt finalement fourni des
drones extrêmement performant aux
ukrainiens il y a tout un jeu de
négociation va aussi je ne pense pas
qu'il y aura une escalade mais il ya
tout un jeu de négociation là la russie
essaie d'obtenir
un satisfecit en mettant des pressions
mais tout le monde sait qui aura pas de
guerre et emma qu'on peut jouer un rôle
intéressant comme un peu sarkozy à
l'époque de la géorgie en 2008 je pense
que la france a un rôle extrêmement
important de d'éléments apaisant avec
l'allemagne d'ailleurs avant cette
majorité mais les majorités compte aussi
dans les pays puisque aujourd'hui de
cette nouvelle majorité en allemagne est
beaucoup plus hostile à la russie que ne
l'était merkel donc tous ces éléments
sont à prendre en considération
jean de gliniasty évidemment la menace
de sanctions économiques
et surtout ce levier dont on vient de
parler sur north stream 2 c'est ce qui
peut être compliqué pour les russes mais
aussi pour l'europe qui est directement
concerné finalement
les russes c'est à dire que compte tenu
de toutes les sanctions qui se sont
accumulées depuis
6 7 ans il voit pas ce qui pourrait
arriver plus sauf la suppression du
système de compensation swift qui
évidemment les couperet du monde
bancaire occidental ça c'est vraiment
l'arme atomique
sans doute les américains ont ça en tête
on ne discutera des sanctions
extrêmement grave les russes s'y prépare
depuis longtemps qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
mis au point un système mir qui
pourraient être comparables qui
s'applique uniquement aux pays avec
lequel la russie commerce beaucoup c'est
à dire la chine et d'autres pays en tout
cas ceux qui n'appliquent pas les
sanctions mais je pense que la russie
est prête deuxième vous parliez de nord
stream deuxième élément nord stream
c'est très simple nord stream de sons
tiennent à quand l'allemagne et si
l'allemagne en a vraiment besoin donc en
ce moment il se trouve qu'on a plutôt
besoin de gaz russe et donc je pense
qu'à un moment ou un autre nord stream
fonctionnera donc à mon sens c'est une
menace qui n'est pas qui n'est pas très
crédible mais qui fait partie de
gesticulations nécessaire mais comme sur
le son je suis persuadé que malgré les
tentations on pourrait avoir parfois à
moscou d'aller régler la sphère en
ukraine par la force il n'y aura pas il
n'y aura pas d' escalade et que nous
avons assisté à une une immense pièce en
fait on a fait monter les enchères avant
on a montré qu'on était le plus fort
chacun de son côté et maintenant je
pense que le soufflé tout doucement va
redescendre merci en tout cas jean
dynastie je vous libère je crois que
vous avez des des obligations ce soir
erwan max erwan gastineau justement sur
ce que vient de dire un jean de
gliniasty
joe biden qui a précisé que l'envoi des
troupes américaines pour l'heure n'était
pas d'actualité donc ça qu'au report est
ce que on vient nous dire finalement
beaucoup de gesticulations montre les
muscles mais rien de grave
joe biden qui dit nous avons une
obligation morale et légale envers nos
alliés de l'otan une obligation sacré
qui ne s'étend pas justement à l'ukraine
ça veut dire en gros voilà on gesticule
effectivement mais pour le moment on ne
va pas aller plus loin que ça oui je ne
crois pas que l'on va aller au delà de
ça comme vous dites je ne contredirai
pas mais mais mes interlocuteurs je
crois que en effet chacun chacun oui
mais en l'occurrence suis en phase avec
ce qui a été dit je crois que chacun
joue sa partition on connaît très bien
en effet les positions de la russie
vis-à-vis de l'otan et des avancées de
l'otan jusqu'à sa frontière je crois que
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
encore une fois j'y reviens et celle de
l'europe emmanuel macron va demain
annoncé quels seront les grands axes de
la politique française lorsque la france
prendra la présidence de l'union
européenne il est question de renforcer
la souveraineté européenne notamment
l'autonomie stratégique européenne d'un
point de vue français y compris
vis-à-vis des etats-unis or ce qui est
sûr c'est que les tensions que qui
existe aujourd'hui un haut niveau au
niveau ukrainien ne vont pas renforcer
la cohésion de la cohésion de l'union
européenne sur ce dossier et je pense
évidemment à la pologne je reviens d'un
déplacement à varsovie il est clair que
pour la pologne le danger russe est
toujours présent cet épisode va leur
arriver et ce qui s'est passé à la
frontière avec la biélorussie et pour
les polonais très clairement une
nouvelle tentative de déstabilisation de
la russie
donc le nerf de la guerre se passe
aujourd'hui en pologne si l'on veut que
demain en effet l'union européenne
disons plutôt l'europe est une velléité
propre sur la scène géopolitique et
s'affranchisse de la tutelle américaine
alexandre del valle le mot de la fin
pour vous aujourd'hui quelle sortie de
crise quelques est l'issue la plus
probable selon vous alors quand on sait
que en mai dernier il y avait cent
quarante cinq mille soldats russes à la
frontière de l'ukraine est aujourd'hui
une à 100 milles et de l'autre côté on a
deux cent cinquante mille soldats
l'ukrainien a armé officieusement très
très bien par les occidentaux mais aussi
parlé par les turcs par les américaines
par les turcs donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la russie n'a aucun signe
elle ne montre aucun signe de vouloir
déclencher une guerre conventionnelle
donc ça c'est la pure propagande et est
ou non de c'est mais chacun a intérêt à
faire monter les enchères pour faire
peur et en fait il y aura une
négociation en gros nord stream 2 qui
normalement doit bénéficier d'une
exception pour pouvoir être validé
puisque vous savez les lois
antimonopoles l'empêchent de fonctionner
il y avait une exception pour north
stream 1 qui avait été négocié âprement
il va falloir la négocier âprement pour
convaincre la nouvelle majorité
allemandes de débloquer et d'accepter
cette exception pour north stream 2
c'est l'exception aux lois antimonopoles
et je pense qu'on va trouver un accord
les russes ont ont trop intérêt à vendre
du gaz aux européens pour ne pas
peut-être trouvé un accord qui sera
peut-être un accord autour de ce qui se
passe en ukraine orienta ce n'est que
mon humble avis merci en tout cas et il
est précieux en tout cas cet éclairage
merci alexandre del rey des mercis à max
erwan gastineau et donc à la jean de
gliniasty qui nous a quittés il ya
quelques minutes merci à vous trois